obesity is not a complicated problem to
solve now it's not complicated it is
simple but that doesn't make it easy and
these are these are categories of things
that we often get confused you know we
see that solving a problem is hard and
then we immediately assume that that
means that it must be complicated but
hard and complicated are not necessarily
the same thing there are lots of
problems that we Face individually in
our lives and also in society that are
very simple problems but they're also
but they are also hard and eating
healthy and uh living a healthy
lifestyle and losing weight if you're
overweight that is a diffic it's a hard
thing to do it's difficult but it is not
complicated